hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
américa latina es corredor y destino
para miles de personas que salen de sus
países de origen corredor por ejemplo
para quienes buscan llegar a estados
unidos- considerado el principal punto
de llegada de los migrantes
internacionales desde 1970 y destino
para muchas otras personas que emigraron
hacia países del sur del continente como
es el caso de los venezolanos por todo
esto la migración es un tema importante
dentro de la agenda política en la
región y es asunto de la cumbre de las
américas 2022 así transcurre el éxodo
por américa latina'
más de 800 personas en una embarcación
con capacidad para muchas menos son
haitianos acercándose a las costas de
cuba la violencia el hambre y la
inestabilidad política los obligaron a
salir de su país con la inseguridad que
matan a uno matando más no no tenemos
seguridad en verdad nadie puede salir
todo el mundo tiene que transferir su
casa pasando hambre entre la casa porque
no se puede salir si empieza un pie
afuera te matan lo malo lo que tienen
seguridad ya son los secuestradores esos
son los que tienen seguridad ya sea que
arman que andan con sus almas así
matando el capitán encargado del barco
los dejó solos y a la deriva la gente
nos engaña porque en mi caso me dijo el
barco más a fidel como
250 hasta 300 personas y el máximo 300
personas según testimonios al menos 15
personas se lanzaron al mar como medida
desesperada y llegaron a cuba al menos
70 niños entre ellos algunos bebés
en su viaje a eeuu la mayoría de los
migrantes recorren kilómetros por tierra
pero otros se aventuran a hacerlo vía
marítima donde los peligros no son
menores a finales de mayo un bote se
volcó en el golfo de méjico y tres
personas murieron algo triste pero que
imaginas a la gente no deja de
intentarlo porque este supone que es
para una vida mejor pues en nuestro país
no crea que está tan fácil la cosa
creo que ya queda como asustado pero vía
terrestre la situación es también
difícil con méxico haciendo de muro para
contener a los migrantes que viajan a
eeuu
en tapachula al sur de méxico miles
esperan un permiso de movimiento para
poder avanzar meses después nada pasa
siempre no vienen a buscar qué
vamos a llevarlo a migración para darle
el permiso lo que se los llevan expreso
para el siglo 21 un engaño total todo el
tiempo y ya tenemos dos meses aquí
negando el permiso así las cosas este
grupo planea presionar y volver a salir
en caravana porque regresar a sus países
o quedarse aquí no es su objetivo
colombia elige en segunda vuelta a su
presidente el próximo 19 de junio y el
país es el principal receptor del éxodo
venezolano por lo que la postura sobre
la migración de los candidatos es un
punto que interesa en la nación pero la
xenofobia aumenta en contextos políticos
complejos manuel a cano aitor txábarri y
lionel púlsar y nos cuentan más en el
siguiente informe
amor y yo
cuatro años han pasado desde que jean
carlos y su familia llegaron a colombia
desde venezuela pero ese tiempo no acabó
con la discriminación que los rodea
especialmente a sus hijos en el primer
grado que estuve estudiando unos niños
le clavaron una punta de la piel en la
pierna verdad y entonces
cuando fuimos a reclamar la profesora
dice que nosotros no tenemos derecho a
reclamar
porque porque somo venezolana cruzaron
una extensa frontera para toparse con
otro tipo de barreras unas que se
dirigen sobre la xenofobia que crecen
ante las elecciones presidenciales todas
votaciones en cualquier país afecta
directamente a toda la población que
esté y sobre todo más a la población
migrante nosotros ahorita estamos en
unas obras porque no sabemos qué es lo
que va a ocurrir con nosotros
son estos momentos de tensión política
que le dan sentido al barómetro de
xenofobia alejandro un joven venezolano
es codirector de la plataforma que
monitorea los discursos alrededor de la
población migrante los comicios
presidenciales encienden sus alarmas
analizamos también todas las
declaraciones que han dado los distintos
candidatos a la presidencia y candidatas
la mayoría ha sido una gran ausente esto
es preocupante porque finalmente unas
políticas más importantes que estuvo el
gobierno eduqué una de las pocas que se
felicitó a nivel nacional internacional
ha sido la integración de las personas
migrantes venezolanas una política
migratoria pionera que no hace eco en la
sociedad colombiana una encuesta de
invamer muestra que 60% de la población
no está de acuerdo con que el gobierno
acoja a los migrantes venezolanos lo que
hemos visto es que cuando se incrementan
los niveles de xenofobia hay mayor
posibilidad de vulneración a los
derechos de las personas migrantes
en medio del panorama gris sobresalen
algunos destellos
como los platos de comida que entrega my
ir a una voluntaria venezolana en este
comedor comunitario a través de este
programa hemos logrado
bajar la discriminación e incluso
tenemos un comedor que es
mayor parte para migrantes venezolanos
entonces ha sido una manera también de
integrarnos a la comunidad a la sociedad
donde en este momento están haciendo
vida pero estas iniciativas no son
suficientes en 2021 más de 60.000
hogares migrantes no tenían acceso a la
salud y más de 200.000 pedían en acción
a miento crítico unos pendientes a los
que se enfrentará quien llegue al
palacio de nariño
a 2030 los países miembros de la onu se
comprometieron a facilitar una movilidad
ordenada segura regular y responsable
esto a través de políticas migratorias
planificadas y bien gestionadas hasta
aquí inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]